each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
then thanks for having me I've been here
all weekend unfortunately there's so
many people here at MSR have been able
to meet all of you had to so I'll
hopefully be able to catch up with some
of you too sometime so doing the thought
would be good if I just sorta give an
overview the research I've been doing
the past few years at Carnegie Mellon
it's sort of give you a sense as to what
sort of the latest stuff we're up to and
for those of you aren't too familiar
basically can fit into these three areas
there's I do a lot of work in pricing
security it's also mobile and ubiquitous
computing as well as human computer
interaction and i also thought it'd be
nice to sorta give you sort of like very
quick overview sort of the past work and
you can sort of see where the directory
has been going to you'll sort of see
there's some there is sort of a method
to the madness in terms of the rationale
where things been going so basically a
lot of my past work has been in fishing
so when i first got to CMU we looked a
lot at why people fall for these kinds
of scams and so if you actually look at
a lot of the security security problems
we have today a lot of it is actually
the person behind the keyboard so it
doesn't matter how many firewalls you
have how much encryption you use and so
on if the person behind a keyboard false
one of these attacks and in fact if you
look at the data it's actually pretty
surprising because recently we've had
the securid problems where they broke
into described by RSA Lawrence Berkeley
Lab's oak ridge national labs Canadian
governments Australian Government's
there's also gmail attacks on State
Department employees and so on so it's
actually sort of you know timely
research we've also looked at a lot of
ways how to protect people too so
basically we use online games as well as
simulated phishing attacks to train
people so basically if you fall for one
of our fake attacks and you get the
just-in-time training and we actually
that was very very effective so in terms
of the results we have about 500,000
people using our software through our
startup and some of the other work that
we did also help you influence microsoft
internet explorer 8 the design the
warnings there we've also had a lot of
people adopting our work by the
anti-phishing working group which is an
international consortium to fight
against crime and also some of these
articles in Scientific American and
communications of the ACM
some of the other work that we've been
doing to is looking at location-based
services too so one of the things that
I've always been really interested in is
you know given that we have all these
mobile devices what can we do with this
kind of location information as well as
how people manage their privacy so one
of the main system with we've been
working on for several years now is this
thing called loca Chino or we've been
trying to understand how do people
specify rules for disclosing their
location information and generally how
do people's concerns change over time
with respect to privacy and sort of one
of the surprising things we found in
this study is that people generally
become less concerned over time the
longer the useless system so generally
speaking they had about four to five
rules and the tender to relax rules to
allow more people to see information
about them over time we've also looked
at things for place naming too so know
the answer to the question where are you
is actually a very deceptive kind of
question here because you know I could
legitimately say I'm in Seattle
Microsoft I'm a microsoft research on
building 99 or room 25 35 and all them
would actually be legitimate answers in
fact you'd also say on the planet Earth
which is true but also sort of useless
too so we also looked at different
models for how people named these places
and how do we automatically infer those
two also alternative visualizations of
locations so for example you know rather
than just showing maps of where people
are you might also show other kinds of
visualizations do one of the main
reasons for this is it turns out people
don't like disclosing the location of
their home on a map and it's also not
very useful because a lot of people
don't know where home is for that
individual but just having a label home
turns out to be quite useful if you
haven't used the system Foursquare I'll
also talk about a little bit of that
later on but it's actually a serve a
surprising system they claim to have
about 20 million users so and we're
looking at why do people actually use
this system it's actually a really
interesting one too because if you've
studied ubicomp research and
location-based services for a while you
know there's been so many failures in
terms of people not using the system
with even building and i would say four
score is really the first time we've
actually had large adoption of one of
these location-based services that isn't
just navigation and we can finally start
studying you know what is the
interesting parts here why do people use
it what are the interesting kinds of
ways that they've co-opted be systems
and we've also had one startup I'm not
affiliated with this one but looking at
commercializing some of this technology
so those are like Act one of the
research career so you know what do you
do for a follow-up on this one so what
I've been looking at more recently is
you know these smartphones do so smart
phones was always a main theme of the
research but you know we've been looking
a lot more at this because of the amount
of good that can be done with this as
well sort of the evil that can be done
with that too and remember you can only
use your powers for good so you know if
you look at these smart phones you know
I'm guessing probably almost everybody
here as one of these smart phones they
have your location data they have your
call log data SMS pictures your contacts
list they know what apps you run and so
on all this rich amount of data okay so
what can we do with this in terms of
good so two of the things that we've
been looking at to the research thrust
you know what is this augmented social
graph so how can we use this data to try
to build better models of who we know
and how well we know them and so on and
I'll give you some reasons as to why
this might be useful another big threats
are we looking at is this thing called
urban analytics so once you have
location data thousands of people in a
location what kinds of things can you do
with that and so we've been using this
try to understand the character of a
city and the last thing I'll talk about
in this talk is well the opposite side
of things how can we actually protect
this information from other kinds of
people or malicious has attackers so
I'll talk about some of the work we've
been doing on crowd scanning where we've
been trying to use crowdsourcing to
understand the behavior of these apps
and so I'll start out with this
augmented social graph and the main goal
of this one is to build a computational
model of a person social graph so this
includes a person's tie strength
relationship and roll so if you look at
for example your contact list in your
smartphone or if you look at a lot of
these social networking systems a lot of
them are like this or are you just have
a blob of friends and it doesn't really
have much understanding of well you know
is this your family member is this a
close friend is it someone you've never
actually met in person so there's all is
rich data that isn't being captured
there and what we're trying to transform
that into is something more like this
where it would know well these are your
close friends these are strong ties
here's your weak ties out over in the
periphery and also might know these are
your new york friends these are the
surfing friends is your family and so on
yeah
right so that's a separate question
first of all we're looking at it can we
even build this the second part is where
should actually live so does it belong
to say you know its service provider or
just belong on your phone for privacy
reasons we would probably argue more on
the phone and plus a lot of the other
data sources that were drawing on
they're not really integrated so that
would be the most likely scenario is
that you'll be living on your phone
yes well that's sort of the next slide
why would you care about this yeah Brian
every question right oh yeah that's
actually really good idea in fact these
images are actually adapted by from Paul
Adams slides farms was the guy who
helped do a lot of the ethnographic work
and interviews that led to google
circles but then he also left right
afterwards and now that Facebook so why
would you care about this so in some
cases you know one might be secure
invitations this picture is a person of
someone named robin stage and it's not
really her name but basically a black
hat hacker we're trying to find out how
many people can i trick into friending
this individual and so basically try to
strategies a get attractive young woman
and be threatened people who just
basically accept all friends friend
implies and then by the time I want to
get to you then it's like hey you know
there's 12 people also know her and Plus
you subtract so that's sort of a sort of
this strategy that they were using so
you can imagine if you had one of these
things you might be able to say well you
know all 12 of these people have never
met her face to face and something like
that could actually be useful in trying
to prevent these kinds of attacks
communication triage might be and other
ones they're trying to prioritize who
you're trying to communicate with
understand who the different individuals
are better information finding so the
weak ties it turns out is much better
for finding new information so one thing
I was time Jaya Andhra cool is that well
you know one of the things we know
social science is that you tend to know
the same information that all the other
people around you know and so that's why
it's actually useful to bring me in
because I know a completely different
set of information and have a different
sort of heuristic and thought process
which can bring in certain your
information for configuration of privacy
policies is another one too we have a
study done you become 2011 showing that
tie strength is actually strongly
correlated with what you're willing to
share with other individuals now this is
actually too surprising I mean you're
probably more willing to share things
with your close family and friend we're
actually just the first ones to document
what are the kinds of things that people
are willing to share with you and the
other one that we're also looking at
this one is one of the main kinds of
applications we're looking at this other
one is the other one we're spending a
lot of time on the lady texting a
depression so if we know for example you
have less communication with your strong
tie and combined with other smartphone
data like your mobility seems to be
going
down you're going to lots of fast food
restaurants which turns out to be
strongly correlated with depression so
if you guys are going lots of fast food
restaurants yeah be careful of it and
the main reason is basically loneliness
it basically suggests that you're not
eating with friends if you go into lots
of fast your growth and insomnia is lost
something probably detect on this one
yeah yes it would be grad students and
parents with new babies is another
possibility so we're aware that kind of
possibility too okay so this is our
first foray into this which is using
location to infer the friendship so this
is basically an opportunistic research
because using local chino we've actually
collected a lot of data about where
people were going in pittsburgh and then
when the grad students had this insight
which is well you know can we actually
use this data to infer interesting
properties about these individuals are
the places that they're going and one of
the main things to take out of this is
actually this notion of something called
place entropy so place entropy we this
is an idea that we borrowed from
ecologist so they're trying to
understand the species diversity in an
area so basically take any kind of area
square meter square kilometer or
whatever count the number of unique
species there and then use the same
entropy formula that you would see from
Claude Shannon so they borrowed from
Claude Shannon and we borrowed from
colleges and then this gives you sort of
a sense as to the number unique species
seen in area we did the exact same thing
except looking at your numbers of unique
people assignment area and this are
gives you a sense of the social quality
no place because you know if you are in
a place with high entropy that means
there's lots of people seem there which
probably means it's a more public area
but if you're in a low into place then
its place where very few people go and
so this might give you a sense as to the
kinds of friendships that might or a
better signal of friendship because if
you're co-locate with someone in a hind
replace that's not very strong signal
because you know right now and I'm sorry
you're co-located with probably hundreds
of people and that you don't really even
know where as if they're co-locate in
your home which is a loan to replace
that's a much stronger signal that
you're positively friends yes we do in
this case is roughly about 30 meters by
30 meters basically if you take a GPS
grid latitude and longitude and it's
roughly like point zero zero two and
then just basically turn that into a
grid and it turns out that that was a
really simple model is having to work
really well and you don't have to worry
about what's a place what's not
place and salt so we lose a lot of
semantics but it's far easier to process
you know how to worry about a lot of the
messy semantics issues aside your
question
right yeah
bye
not yet but I'll show you some other
surprising things that we found for it
too and you're I think you're right to
that if we can get more semantics about
these places we probably could do much
more interesting things so we haven't
gotten around to that yet but you know
there's a lot of these kinds of you know
yellow pages we could use you know the
web pages with street addresses we could
use and so on to get a better sense of
what's going on okay so here's the
entropy map for Pittsburgh it's a little
bit messy on this projector basically
here's Carnegie Mellon it has a lot of
red areas where it means high entropy
over there's here is a dining a shopping
area right next recording on which is
called craig street for familiar with it
and here is also a very high entropy for
obvious reasons because that's where we
go out to lunch here's the residential
areas which are very low entropy areas
ok so this sort of matches what you
might expect to this doesn't work well
for urban areas but it seems to work
well for sort of semi urban areas like
this burg and so what we did is we
develop 67 different machine learning
features so we had things like location
diversity and entropy so again are you
colocated in a place with high inch for
your launch review intends to be in
duration so duration is how long you've
been using our system intensity is how
many different collocations you have
with us or with another person mobility
is do you have sort of a regular
schedule or do you have sort of erratic
schedule specificity is basically tf-idf
is this a place where I spend a lot of
time in and lots of other people don't
so an example that would be my home in
my office and this also graph structure
so how many mutual neighbors do you have
and how much of overlap there is and so
it turns out we used svm classifier and
we got about ninety two percent accuracy
in protecting friends or not though
that's actually sort of misleading
because prior probability of people not
being friends is actually pretty high so
instead what shows a precision and
recall grass and sort of the main thing
is to get out of this is that using
features like location entropy really
does help improve things rather than
just where the shallow features of rocko
locations so the wrong collocations is
over here here's the precision recall
graph you see it's actually not that
great when it starts out over in the far
left side and then as you add in the
different kind of feature is the
precision recall actually doesn't prove
pretty well so you can see right here
here's the full model and it does much
better than trying to predict who's
likely be friends yes
yeah includes all the different features
i mentioned here yeah I'm pretty sure
that would be too I don't know offhand
but yeah it's a good question another
sort of interesting finding we had is
you can actually correlate number of
France based on mobility patterns too so
basically people who go out to hi
interview places especially weekends or
people go out often especially on
evenings and weekends tend to have a lot
more friends than people who dumped and
then you know we thought about this for
a second it's like well you know exit it
doesn't make sense because you know
here's this grad student who goes to all
these different parties and look at my
own location patterns is like wow work
homework home airport work on work home
so you can probably guess you know my
friends number friends of Facebook isn't
that really that high but this is
actually sort of interesting it's sort
of suggests to us that just based on Raw
location patterns we might building for
other kinds of characteristics about
individuals as well too so you know one
obvious one that people talk about this
well maybe you can refer people's
personality type space off of this kind
of stuff too so we had ten variable
model r-squared value it's reasonably
good so point to one but here's what
sort of another interesting finding
we've had with entropy which is that
entropy also seems to be correlated
pretty well with location privacy
concerns so this graph basically shows
you on x-axis here is the entropy of
location so zero means basically you're
the only person seen there and for
supplies means lots of people are seen
there and we had self-reported comfort
level in different locations so one
major not very comfortable sharing a
location with this group conforming is
you're very comfortable sharing your
location with that group and so friends
and family are the ones that the top bar
so people are gently okay with sharing
the location but here's the interesting
one which is this is everybody and
you'll see it actually goes up as the
entropy goes up as well too so they also
suggest to us well you know maybe this
could be a useful way of generating
default policies for entire city without
really knowing any of the specific
individuals so you can imagine well if
you're trying to employ a new kind of
location-based service this might tell
us well these are the places you
shouldn't be recording people or sharing
the location and here's locations where
they might be okay with sharing the
location so this sort of early result
this is awesome you become 2010 if you
want to see the full paper but we think
this might
the server promising direction for
location privacy in general our ongoing
work in this is trying to get richer
data too so the past work with just
location data what about you know all
the other smartphone data I mentioned so
the current work we actually been
collecting facebook data smartphone data
and ground truth data from 40
participants the ground truth data
basically is what is your self-reported
ty strengthless individual on a scale of
one to five which groups do they belong
in so you can create your own groups and
also we did this for 70 different
contacts and we're using this to model
tie strength in groups and so just to
give you sort of intuitive reason as to
why we think this will work well so this
is actually my call log data this is my
wife's contacting me you know if you
just sorted based on raw number of calls
she's number one and of course the first
time I showed her this she said I don't
call you that often but yeah I mean
actually there's lots of these small
calls and just a few of these long calls
as well too also calls every day of the
week as well as at all times here's my
brother sort of the same pattern is my
mother you can see once you actually
went overseas because they serve a drop
off from this calls here but if you
compare this to sort of like other
individuals so here's like one friend
here's the unknown and here's one of my
best friends here so you can sort of see
a different kind of pattern like long
cause but not very often so that's sort
of the current work that we're doing and
we're trying to analyze this and build
much more of these models and see how
well they work and as well how well they
generalize do okay so that's where the
first part of the talk the augment is
social graph the next thing I wanted to
talk about is the work we've been doing
in urban analytics and sort of the
rationale behind this one is that
today's methods for understanding what's
going on in city is really really slow
and expensive so for example Minnesota
does this thing called a travel
behavioral inventory to try to
understand traffic flows and they do
this every 10 or 20 years so basically
they give GPS to baby about a hundred
people and they recruited by a thousand
people to do Diaries studies of where
did you go where are you going why are
you doing this and where do you start
where you end and so on it turns out
that this travel behavioral inventory
dictates all the resources they allocate
for the next ten years right and so you
can imagine this is pretty coarse grain
it's small amount of people and it's
also fairly coarse grained your census
costs about thirteen billion dollars to
do
and there's still processing the data
quality of life survey is also done by
sociologists and city governments so
this is where they go door-to-door in
specific neighborhoods and they ask you
you know how are you feeling today did
you manage to buy any fresh food today
and other kinds of things to understand
how is your life generally doing and
they do this it's very expensive to do
this because you can only do it in a few
small areas it requires army of grad
students or an army of hired
professional interviewers and also a lot
of time to do this to brians you have a
question
I think this yo census is all this
amazing information about how to get
people to be motivated to race
participation it turns out one of the
main things to raise participation is
that's why you get the postcard saying
you're about to receive one of these
things and then you receive it and you
know the question is why don't they just
send it to you and they actually have a
lot of studies showing that sending the
postcard increases the response rate
pretty dramatically which is really
strange but it actually works so this
whole sort of science in terms of
understanding how to get people to do
this in fact there's a whole science in
terms of getting people to donate money
to charities as well too it's sort of a
separate kind of topic that it's really
fascinating work ok so what we've been
doing here sort of the vision for urban
analytics is let's take smart phones and
social media and machine learning
together to try to generate you and
useful insights about what's going on
inside of the city so to try to
understand the structure and the
character and the dynamics of what's
going on and part of the reason for this
you'll notice the new thing here is the
social media compared to the past work
and the main reason for this is because
you know again we only had four hundred
eighty nine participants 2.8 million
location sightings which is something
that's a lot but it's really not it's a
really small sample it's also you know
pretty bias in terms of who are getting
we also don't have a lot of coverage
around the city and this is where the
social media I think can really address
the problem I think this is really the
sort of new angle that will really help
us be able to do this yeah
yeah yes so that's something we've
talked a lot about to with some of the
folks at Carnegie Mellon and if one the
early studies we did was just plotting
where people are taking geotagged flickr
photos and there's like a huge gap in
Pittsburgh where it's it's pretty clear
it's a lower socio-economic boundaries
and so we don't have a good solution for
that yet but serve our suspicion is that
as the cost of these kinds of
technologies lower and to become more
pervasive and I think that it might
become a problem it solves itself in
time but you know in the short term and
the core we currently are it's nothing
going to the problem in fact you'll see
other biases which I'll point out and
how we're doing our method right now but
despite these methods we're still
finding some pretty interesting results
too
right
right i mean this sort of goes back to
the old kind of question quantitative
versus qualitative and you know I'm a
fan of these mixed methods to understand
sort the full picture rather than just
relying on one of these methods and so
you'll see actually that we use the
combinations and methods so we do use
some of the machine learning but we also
use interviews to evaluate how well the
machine learning techniques were working
so here's our first urban analytics tool
it's called live foods and you can also
check it out on live foods org we have
four cities right now so at Pittsburgh
San Francisco Bay Area New York and
Montreal so we don't have seattle yet
but if you're familiar with those other
cities you can also take a look and sort
of the working assumption we have here
with live codes is that the character of
a place is to find not just by the
places that are there but also by the
kinds of people that are there too okay
so let me give you sort of an example
what I mean by this so you know think
about your own home neighborhood and so
the also hi you're probably not thinking
of you know sort of the political
boundaries or something like this in
fact you know when we talk to giving
this talk several times to lots of
different groups we've only found like
you know really one person who thinks
like this and it was urban planner
essentially whose job is to think it was
something like this but it's more likely
you're thinking more like this so you're
thinking of okay the kinds of people
that are there kinds of stores that are
there you know this is sort of like a
safe place you know has nightlife and so
on and so this is really nice quote by
this individual named kevin lynch
acceptance cut off there it's every
citizen has had long associations with
some part of his city and His image is
soaked in memories and meanings and you
know one thing that's really fascinating
about Kevin Lynch is he actually did a
whole bunch of these studies to try to
understand how people understood their
own city so he actually had a lot of
people draw maps of Boston and to
understand how they navigated and how
they understood the city and sort of one
really funny finding had There was that
in Boston the everyone's conceptual map
of how it work didn't match at all what
the physical layout of the city was
because if you ever been in Boston
apparently is like all these curvy roads
and there's no grid is really confusing
and when the main findings he had was
that well you know everyone navigates
based on landmarks so they'll say okay
go this way go past that store and then
take a left whereas I've noticed
adil it's like everything's a grid you
know it's like we're up to one hundred
twenty ninth street or thirty fourth
Street I suspect everyone here by
navigating on the grid because as much
easier to do stanley milgram this is the
famous stanley milgram he's the one due
to six degrees of separation the shock
experiments and well it turns out he
also did other cool stuff to that didn't
involve you know like violating all the
human subjects fools but you know very
very influential well they didn't exist
but he helped influence their existence
but one of the cool things he did was
ask people to draw maps of their city
too so he also had the same thing and so
he did it for Paris as well as Manhattan
so you can see here sort of Manhattan
Island so I sort of people draw this
wider here the central part here's the
financial district Statue of Liberty
which probably is more like over here
realistically and so you know this is a
sort of like one person's conception of
what they thought you know man how to
look like and so here we sort of see
this difference they're sort of the the
formal fixed boundaries defined by the
government and they're sort of like
people's understanding of what's going
on the character of what's there and
sort of what goes on there as well as
organic boundaries and so sort of what
we're looking at here was well can we
automate some of the ways that trying to
identify the organic boundaries sorry
the difference between the formal
boundaries and people's perceptions of
them here also try to understand sir the
local knowledge and can we also try to
build our collective maps of these
things after
right right right that's really good
point
right okay
the Big Dig okay right right that's
actually a really interesting point I
don't know i don't think that these
studies controlled for that they're just
basically asking people who lived in the
areas the only kind of study where I've
seen where they do have other kinds of
variables this is actually published in
the most recent hi just looking at
Foursquare usage and how it affects
people's cognitive maps sort of the
surprising find that they had was that
people who use foursquare tend to know
more neighborhoods than people who don't
write and this sort of suggests that
that actually is one of the effects of
foursquare which encourages people to
explore more areas of the city so that
might be sort of a positive thing but I
haven't seen other studies and describe
what you were saying and that actually
might be a really interesting one to do
too okay so going back to this so what
we're trying to do again is look at the
differences between the political
boundaries and people perceived
boundaries and look at different
techniques for trying to understand this
and sort of the way that we're doing
this was using foursquare basically what
we did is we crawled 80 million
check-ins from foursquare if you haven't
used foursquare before it's sort of a
game where you can say where you are and
share your location with other
individuals they claim to have about 20
million users so you know probably
divided by two or three because you know
those internet services are like that
probably have really long tail users but
what's really interesting is you know
this is what you would see if you use
foursquare right now you would see okay
here's the building 99 you can check
into it yesterday when I got the
screenshot there are two people were
already checked in I was one of the two
it turns out and you know all the
different kinds of things that are
nearby now by default for squares
private so you don't actually see in
these check-ins what we did is we found
people who linked their accounts with
from foursquare to Twitter and then we
look for the public tweets where they
said you know jason has checked into X
and then we just called for those
afterwards what we did is we use
spectral clustering based on Geographic
and social proximity so I'll give you an
example serve into a diversion what that
looks like so imagine this is New York
City and you have these two people who
are roughly going over only in these
areas over here and yeah these
individuals that are only going over to
places in this area and if you could
imagine a graph version of this then you
know this graph right here the thickness
would indicate that lots of people who
go here also go to this location but few
people who go here also go here so
suggests that there's not a very strong
time between those two things and then
basically what spectral clustering does
is it tries to find you know the weak
areas where you can sort of split the
graph and then start doing the
clustering based off of that so sorry
from an intuitive perspective this is
what you might end up with if you had
sort of that kind of graph structure and
so if you again if you want to check out
the live hood site it's like hoods org
let me take these through sort of what
we did with the evaluation others so
what we did is we interviewed 27 locals
who lived in Pittsburgh their residents
urban planners as well as businesses and
we also to draw their mental maps of the
areas that before they actually saw her
on that so we want to get the sense as
what did they think about their city
first and then we want to compare their
mental map to our mental math and so we
showed them our maps and then also
showed some gave them some feedback now
I'm going to tell you sort of a server
case study with respect to the south
side of Pittsburgh so this sort of gives
you a sense as to what's outside
Pittsburgh looks like sort of more of
the hippie area there's a lot of bars
and a lot of tattoo parlors and so on so
yeah definitely area I spent a long time
in as you can tell so here's here's sort
of like one way you might conceptualize
south side of Pittsburgh if you only
knew the geography and if you had if you
knew where all the stores were but you
didn't know anything about the character
of the place like again who goes there
so this is Carson Street the high logic
area so you have a lot of restaurants
tattoo parlors clothing a furniture shop
and this is really the area that
everybody goes to for nightlife you have
this other area called southside works
this is a mixed-use outs or outside
shopping mall and they also have some
condos upscale restaurants and so on you
have this older a strip mall area which
is has a supermarket and a grocery store
there there's also liquor store auto
parts mall and so on and then you have a
whole bunch of residential areas where
people having to live so again this is
sort of if you just only knew what the
stores were you might construct a map
like this now let me show you sort of
what the map looks like based off the
light weights that we had and then I'll
also talk about the interview
results where people are trying to
describe well you know did this make
sense or not in fact one thing that's
really funny is that you know when I
mentioned that to people in Pittsburgh
that we found several areas inside of
the south side even before they say the
map they usually guess this one pretty
fast this is really easy one but the
surprising thing is everybody says oh I
bet there's a splitter on eighteenth
Street which is right where this is and
I'll explain in a second why that's the
case but it's really funny because
everybody per tix that one so the first
one is okay everyone again finds this
split not very surprising but you know
everyone says that the southside works
mixed-use area is very different from
everywhere else the next part is this
one right here so I mentioned this
before that there's a splitter on
eighteenth Street one thing that's
interesting is that there's a change in
geography so it goes from really short
streets where you have no parking to
longer streets where you actually do
have parking so that's sort of one
difference here sort of another
difference and again the main reason why
this is split on eighteenth street is
that this is where the bars end as well
too so basically what happens is there's
a bridge and Duquesne University
students they cross this bridge they go
bar-hopping they get to hear they see
the UPS store and they turn around
because there's no more bars to go and
again people are saying there's a very
different feel here if you go to Google
Maps or any other place where you can
see these kinds of things you can see
that there's just very different kinds
of stores there's a shift there where it
goes to more like these formal
restaurants it's sort of more upscale
kinds of things rather than story these
dive bars in terms of safety people also
mention this to so whenever I was living
down at fifteenth Street so that's over
here on the left side but I was going
down fifteenth Street I had to worry
about drunk people following me home but
on the twenty-third Street which is in
like foods aight i need to worry about
people trying to mug you so it's
different it's not something i had
anticipated but there's a distinct
difference between the two areas of the
south side and the last one this is my
personal favorite one this is
interesting mix of people over there in
left foot six again that's the shopping
area where I don't see walking around
the neighborhood I think they're coming
to giant eagle as your local grocery
store from lower-income neighborhoods I
always assume that came from up the hill
and in fact let me show you this one of
the features we do have in life foods is
to show you what are the most other
related life is so here's the Giant
Eagle there's that small blue cluster
and this is the hill over here basically
and here's the people who live down the
hill up the hill that personal
describing so this does sort of suggest
that you know these are the people who
are coming to this live foods and again
sort of a different kind of nature of
people that are going in there so not
necessarily people who live in this area
there's definitely some people here but
it turns out that there's no other
grocery stores around here either and
this is something that the system
actually could be used to find now i'm
pretty sure not many of you are from
Pittsburgh sale I want to show you some
other kinds of use of this too here's a
new york city and the brooklyn-queens
expressway well i guess not really new
york city but right next to new york
city and one interesting thing here so
here's some brooklyn-queens expressway
going up here and one interesting thing
is you'll notice how the life is also
split primarily by the highway as well
too and if you've ever read anything
about jane jacobs she was a strong
critic of a lot of these kinds of urban
areas and urban planning you know talks
about how highways are basically trying
to split the neighborhoods and making a
sort of lower quality of life but you'll
see that this actually does seem to be
shown here that you know the life hoods
do seem to cluster around this kind of
this kind of highway and you know when
we showed this to people at Foursquare
as well as American Express they
actually mentioned that you no one
really useful use case of this which is
recommender systems if you're going to
do a recommender system using raw
geography might not be the right way of
doing it because it might actually send
you across to a different area which
isn't really the same feel same look and
feel as a neighborhood you're currently
in so this might also be sort of another
way thinking about sort of perceptual
distance rather than just rolla
geographic distance well it could be but
this is one that already exists for us
you know this is one that already is
there I would say and you know I suspect
that if you interview the people there
they probably say the same thing that is
again probably a very different feel
right well I don't have a good answer
for that one but um let me think about
that some more
I'd have to think about that some more I
don't have a really good response or
witty response if you have ever spent
time in berzerkeley or Berkeley you know
what I've done here is I highlighted
sort of the three live foods that was
found and the rectangle also represents
the campus rough kremers the campus so J
this one's for you and you know one
thing is funny is that i had dinner with
a whole bunch of the Berkeley folks last
Tuesday it was describing sort of the
results of this and basically the
southern part of this this is primarily
all the humanities areas the top part is
basically all the signs in engineering
and here's where almost the weirdos
hanging out too so this is this sort of
my mental model and I was actually
surprised I was really pleasantly
surprised to see that there wasn't split
because I know personally I know that I
very rarely spent time down over here I
place go down here maybe once a month or
so so most my time is spent more in the
north berkeley area and i suspect that's
probably true from is the science and
engineering students too so that's sort
of the work that we've done so far i
also want to show you again that this i
think this is the beginning of something
potentially really big in terms of
analyzing what's going on in cities i'm
going to show you too quick
visualizations that students in my
social web class created this past
semester this is sort of a visualization
looking at repeat visits and the total
number of people that went to these
locations in foursquare and so in this
one you can see San Francisco Airport is
very popular for repeat visits but this
one I thought was sort of a surprise
Disneyland Park actually has a lot of
people go there in terms of number of
check-ins as well as number repeat
visits and this wasn't really clear to
me until I actually asked one of my
friends who lives down in Anaheim you
know why is this oh yeah we have an
annual pass to disneyland and we go to
every two months ok because no
disneyland is more replace we drive to
or disney world is a place where you fly
to instead so Playa has fewer people
using white house that was very
surprising probably that means workers
people work there probably checking in
and the whole foods as well to have high
number of people who are visiting and
repeating
this is a display all the data that we
have so this is probably over by three
or four years to point it what kind of
Street Records if you check in twice
yeah oh there are other airports the
other airports are is somewhere
scattered around here it just turns out
san francisco's most popular one I think
this one's also I think might be
Charlotte Airport Brian did Joe comment
total number of people who have checked
in right so it's also mapped to size of
the circle to so as a double mapping
here yeah right that's part of these
other study that we did on foursquare
which is the projection of self you ten
we found out that people liked checking
into cool places and didn't like
checking into fast food restaurants for
example because it did not perceive this
cool but I mean that's that's only
generally true because we've also if you
actually look up embarrassing things and
for school you'll see that there's
actually people check in there too so
look up any random strip club you'll see
that there's someone who checks in there
all the time and it's like apparently
they're okay with that people knowing
that there's a really embarrassing
searcher do in front of people to do it
this is another one that students have
also done and thought this is a really
interesting one if you use topic
modeling the link Deerslayer allocation
on this where you treat the places as
documents and treat the people as words
you can actually find interesting
patterns as well too so for example the
number two turns out you know there's no
label in el día but if you just eyeball
it seems to be tourists placement and so
it turns out this might be sort of an
interesting way of trying to cluster
these and try to find recommendations
for you as well as understand people's
patterns so you can imagine if your
person goes through a lot of these
tourist places we might be able to
categorize you as tourists there's
another one this is like the music
cluster this was the gay bars cluster
which incidentally didn't haul all hold
gay bars it was actually lots of other
kinds of things there that you know I
don't know much about these areas but if
we looked at these places or interview
people it might suggest that you know
maybe these has some more of these
affiliations that you know it's not
obvious just based off of the
you know the location or just the name
of the location so I think there's a lot
of potential here for just understanding
again more about these cities and to do
these kinds of analysis the kinds of
other things we're looking at now is
like howdy neighbor hoods evolved over
time so we're about to get a new whole
foods and want to try to see what the
effects are we also have you know
historical data after before and after
we had a new target in Pittsburgh you
know look at different rhythms of day
versus night so for example you know
downtown most downtown's are very active
during the day but incredibly boring at
night they're basically goes down
tonight and so trying to map those kinda
pattern temporal sequence is something
else want to look at so what do people
do before and after church on Sunday
morning so you can imagine trying to
find those sequences and see this
interesting patterns there that might
help people understand these things well
know that might be one yeah I suspect in
Los Angeles you see something like you
know if you are at home go to church and
then Korean restaurant and you know that
was that probably just because there's a
lot of Korean to go to church in also
demographics as well too so what did
Chinese people do in Pittsburgh so to
give you an example why this might be
useful this is actually a big surprise
for me because I lived in Pittsburgh for
several years I didn't know this but on
Saturday mornings the a lot of Chinese
people go to a Taylor Allderdice high
school and it turns out that's just
Chinese school but I didn't know about
this and I live in Pittsburgh for
several years and so you know in
Pittsburgh itself is actually pretty
easy to do this kind of query because
there's only two Chinese grocery stores
you do sort of repeat visits on you know
Chinese restaurants and then you can
sort filter all that out and try to find
other kinds of pattern and this might be
useful again for recommender systems but
other kinds of things like sociologists
and maybe the urban planners be proud
more useful for these okay so that's
sort of the high-level overview the
urban analytics does anyone have any
other last questions before we going
oh right yeah so one of the right one of
the big biases was the the fact that
it's Twitter and the fact that using
foursquare so that's already two biases
right there but what sort of surprising
to us is that once we release this this
is back in April 2012 we probably had
about 20 different urban planners from
different cities want you to work with
us to try to figure out how do we use
this data for our own city because the
problem that they have is they
essentially have zero data right now and
they're trying to make their best guess
and they can't even present any kind of
data to make arguments because it's just
too expensive to collect it so I would
say that yeah there's going to be biases
but I think something like this could
still help in terms of trying to
understand what's going on you helping
them understand you know origin
destination which is one of the big
things they have to worry about but just
sort of understand you know how
dispersed is a city are people going to
lots of different places no these are
sort of like a central core to the area
so there's all these kinds of questions
that urban planners really need to
answer and I think that tools like this
could really help out
well we put in SF proposal to big data
so we're asking for three and a half
million dollars but whether that happens
or not is a different question but I
mean this is one of the reasons why I've
been talking all these different
companies and so you know American
Express in the foursquare and this whole
bunch of other ones that have been
trying to contact us about this again I
mean they have a whole bunch of needs
for this and parent we stumbled onto
something that has a really strong need
for them and also you know from our
perspective I'm interested in the
science as well as betterment of
humanity in general too so I think that
this could also help out with those so I
think it's going to be much more than
just sort of single undergrad the in
fact I mean it's almost like if I wanted
to do to mimic Marvin Minsky he actually
hired I believe one undergrad one summer
and says okay solve this computer vision
problem so I don't think I wouldn't go
that far but you know I think this is a
really long term kind of thing that's
going to take several years because
there's so many different tools Weaver
ideas for tools we've already come up
with also you know clustering techniques
better algorithms and adding semantics
and so on I think there's a ton of stuff
that can be done yeah
all right right right that's a really
good question so the the issue with
using call call data records is that a I
believe that they only are captured when
you actually make calls and the other
one is that your location to be off by
about a kilometer or so so you get some
pretty good data but you don't get sort
of the data the fidelity that we're
getting so that's sort of a trade-off
because it's also easier to get it from
this telcos and because they have tons
of that data but it's also sort of the
proprietary data that's also harder to
to get the clock get ahold of right yeah
right it's basically a trade-off here
you know so it's like they're they have
huge scale data here we get better a
granularity of data we also know more
about the venue they're at and so on so
I mean there's definitely one of these
trade-offs here personally I don't
really like the call data records
because again it's just sort of the you
know you might be off by kilometer and
that's just like a really big sort of
uncertain area I sort of feel like you
don't get as much out of it because of
that well if we ever found telcos would
work with we could try something like
that I suspect that you know 18 teeth
been publishing a lot of research
recently about how people are moving
around city is trying to build
synthesize models and so on but even
their synthesized models are still off
by about a kilometer in their latest
paper I stole so I think it might be
possible but I'm still a little bit
uncomfortable just because of the
granularity of the data okay so the last
thing I want to talk about here is you
know sort of the privacy size thing you
know sort of the joke is that you know I
spent half my time trying to you know
build better pricing mechanisms the
other half trying to break them and find
other evil ways of applying them but I
wanted to try to give you sort of an
example of motivation is why this is
important so I don't know if many of you
use the Pandora system listening to
music on your phones or smart devices it
turns out that they're actually under
federal investigation because they found
out that it's sharing the location
gender information and unique phone ID
and phone number with advertisers and so
this is one of the big palms that
they're facing and I don't know if the
federal investigation has ended yet but
it's definitely been putting a crimp
into their IPO
there's also other systems to this is
the past mobile social network and
Facebook turns out they're uploading
your entire contact list to their
servers in your entire contact list with
the phone numbers to their server and so
you know this is sort of a really big
surprise because no one really thought
that this was actually going on until
one hacker actually looked at it's like
hey what's going on how do they have
this data and if you look at smartphones
in general a lot of them have these
unusual permissions so Tommy flashlight
+ led requires internet access and phone
number all right your flashlights want
to call somewhere you have backgrounds
require a contact list a dictionary
their parts location bible quotes that
requires your location so some of you
have heard this joke before but you know
the bible quotes you know supreme deity
you need help from smartphones to figure
out where you are apparently so you know
if you actually try to investigate why
this is the case you have you no lies
after actually getting your data for
advertising reasons say they just want
to try to figure out where you are so
they can try to get more targeted ads to
you a few of these are malware but
actually not that much bootstrapping
social networks turns out to be another
one this is why the past mobile social
network was trying to get your contacts
list so they could also try to see if
your friends want to join a closet link
up your social networks and so on
another kind of thing too is that well
it's also just easier to request all
permissions if you're a programmer you
don't know what your future uses are
just say I need everything and then
later on people accept it and then you
can also start using them later on
because people have already authorized
it if you also look at the state of the
art it's also not very useful in terms
of protecting people so this is sort of
an older version what the android
permissions list look like but basically
it's saying you know before you install
this app you know it's going to use your
location course and a course network
base plus find gps location it's going
to read your service configuration
requires full internet access requires
access to all your accounts and also
system tools too and you know there
actually have been studies showing that
people don't understand this and people
don't read this but i think that you'll
probably be able to believe me if I just
say that so here's where the main idea
this is paper that's about to appear at
you become 2012 and sort of the two main
ideas we had here is the first one is a
mental models one so we want to try to
find the gap between here's what the app
is actually doing and here's what people
think the app is doing so try to find
what the differences are between those
two
and the second idea we have here is to
use crowdsourcing to try to find these
gaps so basically we're trying to
crowdsource privacy we're paying people
a little bit of money to try to find
what these differences are and so let me
give you a concrete example the first
one this is actually a picture of my
brother's nissan maxima when he was
still driving that and it turns out he
was driving his car wrong for over a
year before I pointed it out to them and
now that I mentioned this to you many
you'll probably notice exactly what the
problem is it turns out he was drumming
in third gear they said a fourth gear
for over a year and you can sort of see
why he might have been able to do that
because it turns out that he didn't
realize that three and Driver actually
different things and it's left and right
but you also notice here that the only
place where left and right actually
matters and if you have an older maxima
it turns out that you can't have this
problem at all everything's on a single
line so this example actually shows lots
of different concepts in human-computer
interaction but the main 1i only show
you is that you know there's a gap
between the way my brother thought the
car work and the way it actually worked
in practice he just never noticed he
just never noticed it and so he thought
they were the same thing and was driving
before over year in this and I want to
make clear my brother is really smart
guy I mean he's got yeah right
anyways my brother as I mentioned he is
a smart person he's got 12 tesla
roadster is now so he doesn't have this
problem anymore which by the way is
really fun to drive through so this is
you know HDI one of the main concepts
HDI in a nutshell so you have three
different models for any system that
exists there's how you as a designer in
10 people think about the system there's
how people think about the system and
then there's actual implementation and
so you create the system and people
interact with it and that's how they
sort of get a mental model how they
think it works and an ideal world the
design model and the user model should
be sort of well aligned to so you know
if you intend people think it's sort way
hopefully people also think about what
and this is where we come into the
privacy part so let's apply the same
idea of mental models to privacy so we
compare the app to what people expect an
app to do and then we look at what it
actually doesn't practice and compare
what the biggest gaps are between the
two okay so an example is angry birds so
I don't know if many of you have played
Angry Birds before but it turns out it
actually uses your location data and I'm
betting most of you did actually did not
know that so that's an example of a gap
in the knowledge so many of you think
that it does not use a location data but
it actually doesn't practice and if lots
of people have this gap then that's
something we want to emphasize the
second part is how do we actually find
these gaps so our idea here is to use
crowdsourcing and so if you look in
practice very few people actually read
privacy policies in fact I mean the only
time I am aware of when people read
privacy policies is when I assign it as
a homework assignment so and if you
think about it you know there's a lot of
reasons you know we want to install the
app you know we want to play this game
or we want to try to use this app we're
not here to read the privacy policy
reading pricing policies is not part of
your main task again you know you want
to use the app not read the privacy
policy there's a lot of complexity I
mean it's really painful to read a lot
of these kinds of privacy policies
because you don't understand what's
going on and there's also a clear cost
which is your time for very unclear
benefit you don't know what kind of
benefit you going get out of it instead
I idea with crowdsourcing this we can
actually address all fours so if we are
paying people to read these things then
they have they're actually not
installing an app we're just paying them
to read it so there's no app to install
reading these policies is not part of
the main task originally but since we're
paying them now and we're making the
main task it is
now the meantime we can reduce the
complexity by having them only read
parts of the privacy policy at a time
rather than the whole thing and there's
a clear benefit which is we're paying
people to read these things now and so
to sort of jump to the punch line here
this is sort of the interfaces that we
came up with so it's very similar to
what the current versions of the android
permissions look like but the main thing
we're showing you here is surprises so
this is actually from real data that we
captured from crowdsourcing ninety-five
percent of people were surprised that
the flashlight app was sending their
approximate location to mobile ad
providers same thing with unique phone
ID as well too so this is sort of the
result of one of the conditions we had
this other one also has the same thing
but also shows you the reason based on
our analysis as to why is doing it so
25% of users which surprises absent or
approximate location to dictionary com
for searching nearby words it turns out
dictionary the dictionary app that you
can download for android phones it does
use your location data but not for ads
it's actually letting you search for
what are other words people are
searching for near me it's a really
bizarre feature but it's not obvious
that that's what it's doing and if you
sort of take a step back and look at
privacy in general turns out
expectations and privacy is a really
common issue in terms of discussions of
privacy so cats versus United States
this is a really famous kind of court
case where people looking at you know
what are the expectations of privacy for
wiretapping you know can you actually
listen in to someone who's in a phone
booth or not and turns out while it
depends on their expectations of privacy
is the phone if the phone booths door is
open then you probably won't have
expectations of it but if our clothes
and they probably would and so it was
sort of funny it all hinged on some
really basic concepts of how people
thought about privacy a whole bunch of
other philosophical papers looking
privacy also have the same thing how do
these kinds of issues and expectations
affect people's perceptions of privacy
how's expectations are governed by norms
past experiences your current situation
and so on so our main contribution here
is trying to figure out how do you
operationalize the sort of philosophical
notion of expectations and how to use it
in design yes
well I'm not sure if I would agree the
basic premise that people expect more
privacy from the apps than the desktop I
think the main thing is that main reason
we're looking to asses because it's
whatever problem that I think we have
leverage in in the research community
whereas for desktop apps there is no
centralized market it's harder to have
leverage there and so on it's much hard
to understand what the resources a
desktop app is using because there's
nothing like the manifest that says it's
only going to use location these other
kinds of thing so if we had something
like that for desktop apps then I think
we could do the exact same kind of
research but without that I think it's
much much harder to get leverage out of
it so in long term I think something
like that would be really great to do
but I don't know what the best angle of
attack to make attract about this point
so what we did in our study is we showed
crowd workers screenshots and
descriptions of our app this is straight
from the marketplace we showed them the
exact screenshots as well as the exact
same description we showed them
permissions one at a time and only the
ones are related to privacy and we had
two different conditions the first one
is we asked people why do you think this
app is using this permission and how
comfortable they were within and in the
purpose condition we gave them
explanation based on our best analysis
of what the app is doing as well as ask
them how comfortable they were within so
the main differences again is we just
tell them this is what we think the app
is using a 4 and this one is they have
to take the best guess we've created
people from mtor us people only for our
bosa filter to get rid of people who are
probably just just there for get in
quick buck we asked them you know what
version of Android OS or using between
subjects so people were only in one
condition not in both turns out of the
top 100 apps only 56 of them are used on
the Android Marketplace only 56 of them
are requesting use of you know some kind
of privacy sensitive information so
unique phone ID contact list or location
so if you look at this this leads up to
134 app and resource pairs so for
example Angry Birds as for commuting to
an ID and also ask for location so that
would be two of these and then 20
participants prepare / conditions so
basically five thousands of the tasks
here's sort of a quick summary of some
of the results this is a some of the
apps in the expectations condition for
just for location data and basically
what this means is higher means people
were more comfortable with it and lower
means they're less comfort
so you know basically if you ask people
are you okay with google maps using a
location almost everybody says yes
because they can sort of understand why
it's using it for gas buddy that's
basically showing you the nearest cheap
gas almost everybody was okay with that
if you sort of jumped down you'll see
that there's some poor people a little
bit unsure of so here it's like Evernote
how does it actually use location it
turns out if you haven't used Evernote
it's basically tagging the notes that
you're creating so it knows where you
created it so I'll be able to say you
know you create this note in Pittsburgh
and then flashlight and toss it these
tosses the game where you're throwing a
couple piece of paper in a trash can so
it turns out people are very surprised
of this they just didn't understand why
I was using a location data yeah go
ahead
looks likely advertising that'd be my
best guess but maybe okay yeah but you
know if you want to be really
conspiratorial about it you could poss a
well they're in coordination with NSA
and the RAND Corporation to try to track
for all the people you know sir that
value is more fun explanation but jen
has positive effects yeah Jay yeah
that's a little bit surprising we don't
have the qualitative information as to
why people have that perception it might
also be sort of mental model things that
people don't quite understand how poor
square works
to the best of our knowledge is it
doesn't this is just location data Jim I
don't I don't have it offhand I don't
have the variance offhand but one thing
we did see is that people didn't seem to
be a statistically significant
difference between people who use the
app before and people who haven't which
is also sort of a good finding because
that means that you have a larger pool
of people that you can work with to try
to understand this here's the most
unexpected thing so basically those
contact lists the Pandora go launcher
and backgrounds trying to request your
your contacts list we did find a strong
correlation between expectations and
comfort level I think this isn't too
surprising but basically if you add
people did you expect this and how Kirk
for you with it it turns out to be
almost the same kind of question also we
find out if you show a purpose and of
course I know what you want to say next
which is it actually the purpose or any
purpose but if you just show a purpose
it actually does lower people's concerns
so for all across all the different
kinds of permissions so you can see over
here the comfort level point four point
six six and so on so again higher is
better here and so if you have comfort
without the purpose you'll notice that
all they were much lower and displace
you can assume yourself in all cases so
the biggest increases turns out to be
for the dictionary again this is
location it's trying to find nearby
words Shazam so that's the one where it
tries to if you hum the music tuned
we'll try to figure out what song it is
air control lite and other kinds of
things too so again even if you just say
okay we are getting your location and
we're using for advertising that's still
better than just saying we're getting a
location where people have to guess
what's going on and then here's sort of
the main ideas for the new summaries if
we try to simplify the terms and bold
the main permissions try to make it easy
to read we focused on their permissions
that affect privacy so we got rid of
things that didn't really affect privacy
and we also try to sort by the highest
number surprises so the highest one
ninety-five percent cake ninety-five
percent in this case as well as adding a
little icon if it's above a certain
threshold to evaluate the summary we
also try to ask people you know see how
effective they weren't practice we chose
five different mobile apps had these
five apps over here that from based on
previous study use the real data that
was there to show them the same
description screenshots and summary we
asked people
about the app behavior try to understand
are they useful in terms of conveying
the behavior would they recommend the
app to their friends and we try to ask
other kinds of basic questions as well
too and sort of the main kinds of things
to take away from this one is that the
new privacy summary was consistently
more accurate sadistically so where
people could answer questions more
correctly about what the app was doing
it turns out it was faster in 2 of 5
cases but the problem is that people
were still spending 40 60 seconds
reading it so that's still too high from
what our certain goals are so we still
want to see if we can evaluate new kinds
of permissions so see can people
understand this is just a matter of
seconds and we also trying to build a
better kind of tool to help automate
this crowd source analysis so this is
sort of like one of the crowdsourcing
tools you've been looking at we're also
trying to build other one help people
dig down more into what's going on
inside these apps so the ongoing work on
this one we're trying to scale this up
for millions of apps so that one of the
key challenges you saw it took 5,000
Mechanical Turk task to try to just
analyze maybe about 56 apps that's not
going to scale really well where we have
millions of apps so we're looking at
static analysis as well as clustering so
an example the static analysis might be
well it's a game because it's in the
game category and also usually the
location data and it might also use this
story party tool kit so when we try to
slice this up in two different ways and
try to understand are the commonalities
inside of people's perceptions about
these and then based off of this can
start building models I might predict
people's perceptions of what the pricing
will be based off of small set of data
right well that's sort of the idea
behind the clustering idea so if you
look at iphone or android they already
categorize what it is like it's a game
or it's a office productivity it also
has a whole bunch of metadata to like
here's how much cost here's what the
ratings are here's who manufactured it
and so on so based off of all that
metadata plus some basics about the
actual binary of it so based on some
really simple dissection can we start
applying clustering techniques on that
to try to understand it seems to belong
in this category seems to belong in this
category in this category generally has
low privacy concerns or this category
tends to have high partners concerns so
that's sort of the general and technique
that were aiming for right now yeah yeah
so I mean that's another kind of idea
that we can look at or even the reviews
as well too so that's something that we
currently haven't really been looking
you
well this goes to I would say this goes
back to this very last one here how can
we make these things more glanceable
where you can convey the higher order
bids and just or a matter of seconds and
I'm hoping that that if we can make a
breakthrough in that area where it's
useful and effective in just a matter of
second then if people want to drill down
and try to find more I think that might
be an effective way but I understand
your basic question i mean it's it's a
really tough one that I think is beyond
the screen stays yard I think we just
don't know the answer yet yeah well
probably not because people get in your
to it but sort of another strategy that
we're looking at that haven't mentioned
here is that sort of shaming developers
as well as making it easier for them to
understand here's why you gave you a bad
privacy score so that they can start
trying to fix some of those things too
and so you know part of our target
audience if you look at any of these
smartphone ecosystems you can target the
OS the targets of developers the
marketplace or the end-users basically
one of this for kind of stakeholders and
we're trying to look at how we can sort
of impact all these different ones right
now in different countries so the
developers one I think is also an
interesting angle that people haven't
looked at how do you help them make
better kinds of apps that are more
respectable movies there are another
question yeah
yeah that's I think that's a really good
question you know one thing I think
would be useful to do is maybe you can
also apply crowdsourcing at overall
level like would you be willing to
recommend this to a friend which is part
of the reason why we're asking that
question so given that you see all these
permissions do you think this is a good
idea to install this or not and I think
that's sort of like the high-order thing
it should a person like me really
installed it and if we can sort of
summarize them to steal that I think
that probably the most useful one there
might be other kinds of things too like
well I'm not sure they probably have to
think about this more we'll wait till
you're back at CMU can talk about this
yeah so anyways yeah how do we scale
this up are there better ways of
actually labeling the behavior apps so
again this is based off our best kind of
estimate on what the behaviors were
based off of some static analysis some
dynamic analysis and you know doing this
at scale and lastly how do we make these
things more glanceable and
understandable just a matter of seconds
all right so that's pretty much it that
was a whirlwind tour over you know what
we've been doing over the past two years
or so so lots of acknowledgments for all
the people in funding this research and
if you're interested in seeing more and
you know just feel free to contact me
I'm available for lunch and other kinds
of things I'm around here till five
o'clock today all right thank you